欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这节课我们来讲一下关于怎样去收集关键词
把它放到表格里面去统一的管理
那么我们查找关键词的方法有非常非常多
但是我们重点的方向要放在站内查找
也就是在国际站这个平台里面去查找的关键词
才是最有用最有效的词
我们站外找的这些词呢
很多其实可能在站外有很大的搜索量
但是在平台国际站里面搜索量可能是非常少的
甚至是没有搜索量都有可能
所以说我们要去以站内搜索词为主
站外为付
就记住这个逻辑
那么接下来我们根据这些板块一个一个的去看一下
怎么样去找关键词
第一个板块一定是以关键词指数为主的
这是第一个重要的板块
第二个就是引流关键词
加第三个就是买家参谋
还有访客详情
产品360
市场参谋等等这些维度
那么我们接下来一个个的去看
第一个就是在选择参谋里面选
第一个我们找到这个板块
把你确定的词根输入里面去选
然后把这些词找出来
按30天去查找
把这些词导出来
导出来之后
我们把它放在我们的这个表格里面
我们把这些词全部按照这个关键词
按照这些板块
把它排列下来
排列下来
选择参谋权了
那么我们再看一下这个引流关键词这里
我们可以看一下
我们选择这些未设置为产品关键词的这些词
我们也要
去选择出来
把这些我们没有用的关键词
把它们也导出来
导出来之后
我们后面来这个表格全部复制出来之后
我们到时候可以进行一个去从就可以了
这里可以选择选择
这里是引流关键词
那么接着就是我们的
访客详情
访客详情里面是不是这里会有一些
权战偏好的关键词
也就是这个买家收的这一词
只要跟我们相关的
我们也可以去把这些词收集一下
在关键词指数里面去看一下有没有搜索指数
如果他是有搜索指数的
我们可以搜集在表格
如果是没有搜索指数的
我们就没有必要把它搜集到表格了
比如说搜这个词
那么我们来看一下他有没有搜索指数
如果他是有搜索指数的
那么我们就可以
整理到这个表格
如果他没有搜索指数
那么这个表格就不用把它放进去了
不要浪费我们自己的时间
这是第二个板块
第三个板块呢
在买家参谋里面
买家参谋里面会有一个
这些关键词也可以在这里看一下
这买家偏好的关键词
也可以在这里
全站这里偏好的关键词
如果这里是没有的话
那么我们就可以在这个行业买家这里看
处具更大而且更广
这些去看
按照这些去看
你这些类目的话你要去选
选择你的类目
一定要选择你的具体的品类去一个个去分
比如说你要选择某个品类
比如说T恤
你就先收集T恤
比如说你要选择其他品类
比如说毛衣类的背心类的
你就先搜索
把它们整理一个一个分品类去整理
这里也是一样的
你在整理的时候一定是分品类去整理的
一个品类一个品类的去完成
这个就是
我们说的这个买家参谋
先看产品参谋
产品参谋的话
我们是不是在推广的时候
或者是在我们发完产品之后
它是不是会有很多很多关键词在这里
去筛选一些我们没有用的
而且它流量比较好的
比如说你看到某个关键词很精准
但是我们平时没有用能点进去看
是不是它会跳转到这个关键词指数这里
关键词指数的话
你看有关键词指数的
你就把它收集在这个表格
收集在这个表格就可以了
就按照这个这里面的产品一个个点
你这里可以按周
也可以按月去选择
把这些词也是按品类的
比如说你先收集某一个品类的
那么你就先全部都看某一个品类的产品就可以了
按照品类去收
把这些都看了
市场参谋里面的话他会有一些
比如说我们去看这里面点开你们的内幕
内幕的话里面这些
是品类
品类的话我们看一下这买家
买家分析
买家这个板块
是
关键词
这里是
没有
这里没有的话我们就以国家为主
去看这个国家
查国家比如说我看美国的
美国的看看他的一个
搜索品号
有没有
这里搜索品号是不是这里有词
你可以在这里选你的品类
选你啊选好你的品类
选好品类之后再来看词
这些都是词看到没有
不不看这个品类品号
看了热品分析也要看
他的这些
报品标题都用哪些词
这些
都是很厉害的产品
你要去看他都用哪些词
是不是符合你
或者是
有没有你没有用过的
遗漏的词
全部收集起来
这是一个市场参谋的
另一个就是我们所说的平台的定向产品
产品里面会有很多关键词
比如说这些是属性词
属性词
你要去看这些属性词也可以用
这些属性词你可以填在发产品中填上
这些就能够被系统作取了
符合条件都不能
能被系统作取
那么你这里就看这些
通过翻译
因为这里是中文的你要把它
翻译成这种类型的
这种类型的
放酒夹克啊还有上什么
什么
是这些关键词啊你看这些都是包含的关键词你可以去
这样去寻找
这样去寻找里面有很多关键词
可以按照这种方式去寻找
这是
定商中品的
还有就是我们可以在
国际站首页
比如说
这个我们刚才看了
这也看了
这个也看了
也看了
我们在首页的时候
当你收一个产品核心词的时候
比如说你说一个产品核心词
它是不是下面会有这些推荐
这些推荐的话你也可以去
把它写下来
如果你的是APP的话你也可以收一个词
下面会有很多下拉的一些推荐词
也可以
把它收集下来
还有一个我们在发产品的时候
是不是在填写
产品信息的时候
他会
有一个推荐
列表比如说我们随便选一个内容
我们是举例子而已
比如说你在写的时候
是不是他会有这么多推荐
是不是
你可以去按照这样去选择
这标题没有吗
这推荐
推荐都会有
这是发产品的板块
到首页
我们来看一下这个数据概染这里
数据概染的话
下边这里
也有一些词推荐
也有一些词可以用
我们再看直动车
直动车看这个
顶展
顶展这里
现在买词不是可以通过这里来选词吗
这个选词里面是不是很多词
这些词是不是可以选
你可以
行业推荐主词
这些都可以选
选择行业
还有选择相关性
这些都可以选
可以选择你的
要去用的词
这些都可以选
接着就是我们
在创建自动车的时候
他会
推荐的一些
词我们也可以用比如说你创建一个计划他会有一些词
进行推荐的
那么你到时候你就可以按照他的推荐去选的一些词就可以了
最后一个就是我们讲一下站外怎么去选
我们只讲谷歌这几个逻辑是一样的首先谷歌
我们先打开搜索谷歌
搜谷歌的话
打开之后我们把它谷歌趋势输入
谷歌趋势就到这个页面页面之后我们把我们的关键词输入
输入关键词之后它会出现哪个国家
在这个谷歌上面
它的搜索趋势变化, 热度变化, 这个词的热度变化, 你看
从8月, 9月, 8月到10月, 说明这个词
搜索热度是上涨的, 也就是它的需求是上涨的
美国的需求是上涨的, 对于卫一
我们看一下下面它这有这些相关词可以选择
不断翻页翻页翻页去看
这词
是否符合你的需求把它收集起来
另外一种另外很有可能就比如说你在这里
呃你你不确定哪
那些词是不是符合你的需求
比如说你不知道哪些词
是不是符合你的需求那么你就在这里搜
搜一个产品的词进来之后你去看
这里图片
点击图片
图片看这些产品的图片
是不是
我们要
能做的
如果是能做那么这个词就说明他符合我们的需求也可以把它整理下来就可以了你看这里也有推荐看到吗
这些都有推荐
这些词也可以作为你去衍生的关键词但是呢我们最终还是要以
选择参谋里面关键指数里面找到的
核心的词为主
一定要按照那个逻辑去找词应用的话也是
推广
主标题
主要应用的也是
从这个关键的指数这里面去找的
进行应用就可以了
刚才讲漏的一个关于
战略选词的话我们还可以在
ifq市场这里我们去看
客户发的这些产品的这些
需求
看看哪些词我们遗漏的
这些标题哪些词我们遗漏的或者是
点进去
看一下他的描述
那么描述中有哪些词
是有流量的而我们
却忽略的一些属性词
有些词
客户发了但是整个市场都没有
而且最近
很多人收
那么你提前去
用于主标题那么很快就有获得流量
这个概率就非常大而且又快
迅速积累大量的数据
那么你就获得第一批商机
也是这样按照这样思路去查找
那么这就是我们
整体上
关于
怎么样去
找词
收集起来的一些
方法
那么收集的词呢我们可以通过
刚才我讲的那个
表格
你在这里看
这表格我已经把它
分类好了你就按照这里自己
判断去分组
把关键词写下来
这些就是个人的评价跟循环
和TM的总量
就是后期你去推广这些关键词的时候把他们的
数据累计
统计在这里以及你个人对这些词的一些评价
看看他
效果是怎么样的
这样你自己评价好
有利于你后期做一些调整
还有这些
他的匹配的产品的ID是什么哪个词匹配哪个产品
转化是比较好的
他的一个搜索指数
预估
这些什么曝光点击等等这些数据都可以累积在这里
当然如果是你
前期
没有空的时候你
这一部分可能就先不做
但是呢你前面这些你要
先做这一部分就可以了
先做这一部分
你把这些词统计下来
分类慢慢后面慢慢完善这几个部分就可以了
那么这个整个词库就逐渐的构建起来
就可以应用起来了
后期这个词库怎么用呢
第一个可以用于去组合标题
去挑选里面一些好的词
去匹配我们当前
更加热门的款式
第二个就是你知道哪些词
对于哪些产品转化比较好
那么我们在推广的时候就重点推广这类词
这样的话我们很多工作就节省了
而且是非常有效的
所以说这个词表是非常重要的
我们一定要去
持续的积累起来
特别是一些冷门行业
他词本来就很少
如果你把这个做好了是不是
就能够非常清晰
的知道哪些词转化好
而且是哪些词有排名
以及哪些词没有用
是不是非常清晰
那么这个表格就能够
非常精准的指导你怎么样去
操作垫付
这样的话你才能够更容易的拿到结果
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见